hello freak bitches it is what it was
just like any other problem that people
go back to I mean at some point it's
it's up to you to release yourself from
that obligation to get upset or feel bad
about something that didn't go right in
the past you know and that's a huge
point because people define themselves
by the past instead of thinking about
who they are now and said they still
look back at a mistake they made and
don't just get past that mistake grow
and learn
but dwell on it I think it defines them
it's the worst thing I met some guys in
band uses singers I've only met him
twice two different times years later
both times he started telling me about
this story about what happened to him
when he was in this anything in this
poor guy has gone on all these years and
he's still focused on the worst
situation that he ever had to live
through yeah and he's so attached to it
well some guys get one breakup and
they're done
some guys one breakup in their 20s will
tank them for a decade I've met guys
like that that yeah you know I came out
here with Sally and you know she fucking
fell in love with her trainer and dude
Sally still move on what is that and
fucking years ago oh oh you know changed
my life bro but Tiger toy are you so
disappointed I can't trust women anymore
oh you stupid fuck you know what if he
got mugged by one person he'd done trust
in people one person was a murderer
let's not trust anybody yeah yeah you
know I heard about Ted Bundy I'm not
trusting people anymore okay great I'm
not sleeping tonight we yeah I mean
there's definitely pitfalls in life
you're gonna run into him we all are
know you can learn and grow if you
survive you pick yourself up you dust
the dust off and then you start going
and I don't let this stuff don't let it
beat you down it's also directly
proportionate to the amount of hardships
that people face in life their ability
to face hardships you know and there's a
lot of folks that live life on a cushy
cloud of marshmallows and bullshit and
then one day something goes wrong and I
mean that's why spoiled kids are so sad
like a spoiled young boy is one of the
saddest things ever a young boy that
becomes a man and can't take care of
himself and his dad has to keep on
rescuing him his dad has to keep on
bailing them out of situations and
giving them
I've met guys like that and that is a
crippling affliction when they don't
have the character themselves to be able
to get by in life they constantly need
someone to help them and bail them out
even as a grown man I've met guys in
their 40s that still need help from
their parents I'm like what the fuck man
you're never gonna get it right because
somewhere along the line they didn't
face enough of the adversity to realize
that there's sometimes you just got to
get up and get shit done there's
sometimes we have to fucking pull
yourself up and you have to push forward
even if you want to stay in bed and if
you don't do that you just keep calling
on your daddy and your daddy keeps
rescuing you
you never develop those tools you never
develop that ability to recognize what
you're doing wrong with your life what's
your age limit you would cut a chick off
at I think I think around 55 whoa you're
a generous man I mean it all depends it
all depends on if she goes to yoga
there's a there's some good-looking 55
out there there are now yeah
there are now yeah and scientific have
you seen Christie Brinkley yes and
that's exactly the type of thing I'm
talking about how old's Christie
Brinkley no she's up there she's hot
it's fog you seen Helen Hunt lately no I
don't need to do that there's this movie
called my boner knows no you're going
the wrong way Christie Bermuda cleanse
my palate
let's take this conversation slow this
is getting exciting there was this movie
called
the session and if you just look up the
preview of it it's about this guy that
has an iron lung and he's you know he's
very like Stephen Hawking and then maybe
just laying there at all you know and
stuff and so Helen Hunt's like his
therapist or something and he goes she's
like oh you need to get laid so she
starts taking off her clothes and you
see her full bush her body was lovely is
this it's called this session just an
old movie you know this came out like
two years ago and it's just Helen Hunt
fucking this retarded get not retarded
at this iron lung guy and it's just
creepy as fuck it's just a creepy
version of Helen Hunt her face looks
weird like okay and and then you just
see her bush and she's having sex
through the whole movie pull up that
picture sounds pretty good Christie
Brinkley bitch disgustingly that's yeah
that's current
okay and she's gotta be how old she's
old look at her throat though whatever
whatever did Jennifer a little tuck this
validates my her wear scarf get her in
the horse rider I would make her drive
in a convertible and chase me around
while I drove in a station wagon up town
girl well if you compare the way she
looks today and the way she looked when
she was with Billy Joel not that
difference compare the way Billy Joel
looks today and the way Billy Joel looks
when he was with Christie Brinkley I
think she's a vampire she stole his soul
do you think this threat things caused
by cock just tons of Kania she's 60
she's 60 years old don't you can't you
don't respond to him with that it's
amazing she's fantastic absolutely
that's as good as a 60 year old woman
who's ever looked in the history of the
world yeah and that's what I mean we're
talking about exceptions when I say yeah
you're not looking at her and going oh
she looks good for 60 you're looking at
her and goes damn she looks really good
she's hot man yeah she's hot and her
body's really nice too
yeah Christie fulchiron Kapow Kapow I'll
take it so I'm taking all day long yeah
you make out with her I'll take that
throat cutter it's not that bad dude a
throat doesn't look bad you're focusing
on the wrong thing yeah what do you you
got a mirror bitch you're gonna be very
good focus on that yeah it ain't that
bad dude come on she's hot as fuck
you're out of your mind you look at her
neck
you're looking at still image who cares
Brian that's nothing you're saying
nothing you're making noise with your
face you're really frustrating me right
now Brian yeah there's nothing going on
with what you're saying you're just
fixating on next next get a lot worse
we'll do whatever you want okay so we'll
vote for you we'll do whatever you want
you just got to do this first well
listen to you give her a big fucking jar
of them with applesauce mixed in look at
her
the Joe Rogan kind of hot in a weird
milky way now I can look at his people's
necks that's not even real bro use
Photoshop that did Brian Brian you hit
the volume Jesus Christ
you fucking
it's like a big dick kind of volume yeah
um Jeff the headphone didn't affect the
recording now just infants you Photoshop
that you fuck I didn't they were stupid
it's a vagina it's not an accusation a
bow and arrow what's going on in her
neck there's a guy named arrow no it's
not
that's Christy brings it real no it's a
real did you really doctor that up yeah
of course it did you fuck he thinks it's
fine
so I'm mature man he put of a giant on a
woman's neck and a woman is running for
Congress first of all it's unpatriotic
regardless whether or not you agree with
her you will respect her it's an
American Brian